We may have found the key to marital peace!
It’s green, it’s pungent, and it’s the
cause for nearly 1 million arrests every year.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
The notion that people who smoke weed are
non-violent peace lovers may be more than
just a stereotype.
A new study in the journal Psychology of Addictive
Behaviors has found that couples that smoke
weed together have staggeringly lower levels
of domestic violence.
Couples where both spouses smoked at least
a few times a month -- which was the highest
end of the researchers’ scale -- had the
lowest levels of violence in the study.
The study looked at 638 newly-wedded couples
over the course of 9 years.
The couples each did an initial interview
and then subsequent interviews after one year,
2, 4, 7, and then 9 years.
Part of the data collection included reporting
their marijuana usage and instances of aggression
within the relationship.
The researchers say that this means marijuana
use can help predict violence levels over
the next year - but they don’t know if smoking
weed has the power to influence violence levels
on any given day.
The sample is also limited to straight couples
in their first marriage.
Veeeery interesting.
Of course, the temptation is to jump to the
conclusion that weed makes people more peaceful
- but there may be other reasons why this
connection exists.
They’ll need to do more research to know
for sure.
One reason that couples that smoke together
are more peaceful may because they’re more
likely to share core values and social circles,
making them less likely to fight.
The researchers also describe the possibility
of a “positive effect” - which is basically
science-speak for “people feel happy when
they’re high so they’re less likely to
fight.”
Another mechanism on the table builds on previous
research - we know that marijuana users have
dulled reactions to threats and aggression,
making them less likely to initiate aggressive
behavior.
What’s even more interesting is that this
study was funded in part by the National Institute
for Drug Abuse - an institution that is well-known
for it’s strong position against recreational
marijuana use.
The study adds to the growing body of research
about the effects of marijuana on individuals,
their relationships, their lives and work.
Here in the US, we really are amidst a giant
green flurry.
Some of you may recall last month the New
York Times did a huge marijuana issue which
called for legalization on the front of the
Sunday paper in big, bold letters.
About half the country now allows medical
marijuana with a prescription, in 2 states
it’s fully legal.
Researchers are watching Colorado like a hawk
- AND the federal government has upped its
marijuana research quota.
Now they’ll be growing 650 kilograms of
weed.
Last year they grew 21.
I expect the research will continue to avalanche
in the coming months and years and perhaps
more policies will be changing in response.
Thanks for joining me for Dnews, we’ll see
you next time.